.
Im Dezember 2019
berichtete die chinesische Regierung
von einem Virus,
das sich rasant verbreitet.
In den folgenden Monaten
traf es weitere Länder.
Täglich wurden es mehr Fälle.
Es war das "mit dem
schweren akuten Atemwegssyndrom
assoziierte Corona-Virus 2",
das die Krankheit COVID19 auslöst.
Bekannt wurde es als Corona-Virus.
Aber was passiert
eigentlich bei einer Infektion,
und was sollten wir tun?
*Intro*
Ein Virus ist nur eine Hülle,
die genetisches
Material und Proteine umgibt.
Nicht einmal ein Lebewesen.
Es vermehrt sich,
indem es lebende Zellen befällt.
Corona könnte sich auch
über Oberflächen verbreiten,
aber wir wissen noch nicht, wie
lange das Virus dort stabil ist.
Sicher scheint die
Tröpfcheninfektion über Husten
oder wenn man Erkrankte berührt
und sich dann Augen oder Nase reibt.
Hier beginnt das Virus seinen Weg.
Als blinder Passagier
reist es in den Körper.
Sein Ziel:
Der Darm, die Milz oder die Lunge,
wo es am schlimmsten wütet.
Schon in kleiner Zahl können
Corona-Viren schwere Folgen haben.
An der Lungenwand sitzen
Milliarden von Epithelzellen.
Als "Grenzzellen"
unseres Körpers auf Organen
und Schleimhäuten,
warten sie nur auf eine Infektion.
Corona dockt an spezielle
Rezeptoren auf den Membranen an
und injiziert sein
eigenes genetisches Material.
Ahnungslos führt die
Zelle jetzt einen neuen,
ganz simplen Auftrag aus:
Kopieren und Zusammenbauen.
Dadurch füllt sie sich
mit immer mehr Kopien des Virus,
bis ein kritischer Punkt erreicht ist
und sie einen neuen,
letzten Auftrag erhält:
Selbstzerstörung.
Die Zelle schmilzt quasi und setzt
dabei neue Corona-Teilchen frei,
die weitere Zellen angreifen.
Die Zahl der infizierten
Zellen steigt exponentiell.
Nach etwa 10 Tagen sind
Millionen von Zellen infiziert
und das Virus überschwemmt die Lunge.
Noch hat das Virus nicht
sehr viel Schaden angerichtet,
aber jetzt wird dein
Immunsystem zu deinem Feind.
Das Immunsystem,
das eigentlich als Schutz dient,
kann dir ziemlich gefährlich werden
und ist deshalb streng reguliert.
Das Corona-Virus
infiziert die Immunzellen,
die in die Lunge strömen,
um es zu bekämpfen.
Das sorgt für Verwirrung.
Zellen haben keine Augen und Ohren.
Sie kommunizieren
hauptsächlich über Zytokine,
winzige Informationsproteine,
die fast alle
wichtigen Immunreaktionen steuern.
Die Corona infizierten Immunzellen
überreagieren und geraten in Panik.
Das Immunsystem
verfällt quasi in Kampfrausch
und setzt mehr
Soldaten ein als nötig.
Das ist Verschwendung
und schadet dem Körper.
Chaos verbreiten
vor allem zwei Arten von Zellen:
Neutrophile
sind richtig gut im Töten.
Leider auch uns selbst.
Zu Tausenden tauchen sie
jetzt auf und setzen Enzyme frei,
die wahllos Freund
und Feind zerstören.
Die anderen Zellen,
die jetzt austicken,
sind sogen. T-Killerzellen.
Normalerweise weisen sie infizierte
Zellen an, sich selbst zu zerstören.
Ganz verwirrt befehlen sie
das jetzt aber auch gesunden Zellen.
Immer mehr Immunzellen
richten immer mehr Schaden an
und zerstören immer
mehr gesundes Lungengewebe.
Sie können sogar
bleibende Schäden hinterlassen,
die zu lebenslanger
Beeinträchtigung führen.
Die meisten Fälle kriegt das
Immunsystem wieder unter Kontrolle.
Es zerstört die infizierten Zellen,
verhindert weitere
Infektionen durch das Virus,
und räumt das Schlachtfeld.
Die Genesung kann beginnen.
Die meisten Corona-Infizierten
haben nur milde Symptome.
Aber es gibt auch viele ernste
oder sogar kritische Fälle.
Die genaue Prozentzahl
kennen wir nicht,
weil nicht alle
Fälle dokumentiert sind,
aber es sind auf jeden
Fall mehr als bei der Grippe.
Bei den schwereren Fällen sterben
Millionen von Epithelzellen ab.
Damit ist die
Schutzschicht der Lunge weg.
Die sogenannten Alveolen, kleine
Luftbläschen, mit denen wir atmen,
werden von sonst
harmlosen Bakterien infiziert.
Das führt zu einer Lungenentzündung,
zu Atemproblemen oder sogar Atemnot.
Die Patienten
überleben nur mit Beatmung.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt produziert
das Immunsystem schon seit Wochen
auf Hochtouren antivirale Waffen.
Den Bakterien, die sich
jetzt zu Tausenden vermehren,
kann es nicht standhalten.
Verteilen sie sich
über das Blut im Körper,
wird der Patient
wahrscheinlich sterben.
Corona wird oft
mit der Grippe verglichen.
Es ist aber viel gefährlicher.
Die genaue Todesrate
lässt sich während
einer Pandemie kaum bestimmen.
Wir wissen aber, dass es
ansteckender ist als die Grippe
und sich schneller verbreitet.
Bei einer Pandemie
wie Corona gibt es zwei Szenarien:
Schnell und langsam.
Welches der beiden eintritt, hängt
von unserer frühzeitigen Reaktion ab.
Eine schnelle Pandemie ist
schrecklich und kostet viele Leben.
Eine langsame Pandemie geht
nicht in die Geschichtsbücher ein.
Schlimmstenfalls
beginnt eine schnelle Pandemie
mit einer sehr hohen Infektionsrate,
weil nichts dagegen unternommen wird.
Warum ist das schlimm?
Bei einer schnellen Pandemie
erkranken viele gleichzeitig.
Zu viele Kranke überlasten
das Gesundheitssystem.
Dann fehlen Ressourcen,
etwa medizinisches Fachpersonal,
und Equipment wie Beatmungsgeräte.
Mehr Menschen sterben.
Und je mehr
medizinisches Personal erkrankt,
desto weniger funktioniert
das Gesundheitssystem.
Dann müssen wir die
schreckliche Entscheidung treffen,
wer leben darf und wer nicht.
Bei diesem Szenario steigt die
Zahl der Todesfälle beträchtlich.
Um das zu verhindern,
muss die Welt, also wir alle,
alles daran setzen, dass
daraus eine langsame Pandemie wird.
Die richtige Reaktion
kann eine Pandemie bremsen,
vor allem zu Beginn.
So bekommen alle Infizierten
die nötige Behandlung
und Krankenhäuser
können weiter funktionieren.
Gegen Corona
gibt es keine Impfung.
Die einzige Lösung ist
deshalb eine Art "soziale Impfung".
Und das heißt zwei Dinge: Sich nicht
anstecken und andere nicht anstecken.
Es klingt banal, aber das Beste,
was du tun kannst,
ist regelmäßiges Händewaschen.
Seife wirkt Wunder:
Die Hülle des Corona-Virus
besteht vor allem aus Fetten.
Seife zerstört sie und das
Virus kann dich nicht anstecken.
Außerdem werden durch die
Reibung die Viren abgetragen.
Wasch deine Hände so,
als ob du nach dem Chili-Schnippeln
gleich Kontaktlinsen
einsetzen willst.
Als nächstes Abstand halten.
Das ist zwar nicht toll,
aber hilfreich.
Also keine Umarmungen,
kein Händeschütteln.
Wenn möglich, bleib daheim,
um die zu schützen,
die die Gesellschaft
am Laufen halten.
Von Ärzten, über Kassierer,
bis zu Polizisten.
Du bist auf sie angewiesen und
sie auf dich, um gesund zu bleiben.
Es kann auch Quarantänen geben,
was Verschiedenes heißen kann:
Vom Reiseverbot bis zum Hausarrest.
Quarantänen sind
mühsam und sehr unbeliebt.
Wir gewinnen dadurch aber Zeit.
V.a. die Forscher,
die an Medikamenten
und Impfstoffen arbeiten.
Kommt die Quarantäne, habe
Verständnis und halte dich daran.
Das alles macht keinen Spaß.
Es ist aber ein
vergleichsweise kleines Opfer.
Der Ausgang einer Pandemie
hängt von ihrem Beginn ab.
Ein schneller Beginn
mit steiler Kurve endet böse.
Ein langsamer Beginn
mit flacherer Kurve,
geht meist einigermaßen gut aus.
Wir alle haben es in der Hand.
Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Großen Dank an
die Expertinnen und Experten,
die uns sehr kurzfristig
bei diesem Video geholfen haben.
Vor allem Our World in Data.
Dort gibt es auch laufend
Updates zur Corona-Pandemie.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2020)